nouvelle crise politique en israël
malgré une alliance avec la droite
radicale et les partis religieux
sioniste benyamin nétanyahou n'a pas
réussi à réunir les 61 députés
nécessaires pour former un gouvernement
après les législatives du 23 mars son
parti le likoud arrivait pourtant en
tête avec 30 sièges sur les 120 que
compte la knesset le parlement israélien
ce mercredi le président reouven rivlin
ne peut que constater l'échec du premier
ministre peu avant minuit monsieur
netanyahu a informé la présidence qu'il
était incapable de former un
gouvernement et donc qu'il rendait au
président le mandat
la suite des événements appartient au
président de l'état hébreu dès ce
mercredi il doit entrer en contact avec
les élus de la knesset pour prendre une
décision laissée la mission de former un
gouvernement à benyamin netanyahou ou
désigner quelqu'un d'autre pour le faire
et les candidats ne manquent pas à
commencer par le député centriste
yaïr lapid qui s'est dit prêt à assumer
cette tâche
le temps pour un nouveau gouvernement
est venu
il s'agit d'une opportunité historique
de briser les barrières qui divise la
société israélienne d'unir les religieux
et les laïcs la gauche la droite et le
centre
au pouvoir depuis 12 ans jugé pour
corruption benyamin nétanyahou ne fait
plus l'unanimité à la knesset
si l'opposition parvient à former un
gouvernement c'est une page de
l'histoire d'israël qui se tournera dans
le cas contraire les israéliens devront
retourner aux urnes pour la cinquième
fois en un peu plus de deux ans